let's talk about credit obviously
personal credit is important business
credit's a whole other thing uh what
would you say is somebody's easiest
course to correct their credit score
let's say that they're hanging around
like a 600 a 580 and they're trying to
get in that 700 range what are some of
the tips that you could give somebody
like that they the easiest thing right
let's say uh your wife has a credit card
right
let's say you wait for example right on
both
um
if she had that credit card for at least
two years right make you an authorized
user when she makes you an authorized
user you get her good credit history for
the last two years wow so and she
doesn't have to give you the card so it
could be a friend it could be a family
member it could be anybody they add you
as an authorized user but you want to
make sure that as a person doesn't
really use that credit card right right
and now by doing that you could go from
a 600 credit score all the way to 100 a
700. wow 720 within 30 days wow once
it's reported so that's like one of the
easiest tricks that you can do to build
your credit score if you if you know
somebody it's almost worth you paying
them to become an authorized user if you
got oh that's the issue a lot of people
do charge for that for trade lines
that's illegal and now you got to be
careful because I have no pic I know
people in the past that actually paid
people and then next you know they don't
pay the balance on the credit card now
you get a late on you and now your
credit's [ __ ] yeah so you really want
to go to like a personal friend family
member yeah someone you trust yeah like
I got one credit card I got like 20
people I don't even use it I just help
out you know my friends they got low
credit scores yeah I would say someone
is saying that um it's my son's 17
someone's saying I can put him on a
credit card but I don't know if he has
to be 18 or not no so my daughter's been
on my credit card now since she was like
14 15. and so when she turned how old is
your daughter uh she's about uh she's 17
she's gonna be 18. so when she turns 18
will her credit score already just being
a good job good credit wow yeah she has
good credit now oh yeah I got it I got
to figure it out the only thing is it's
certain credit card companies like I did
it with a Visa and a MasterCard I tried
to put her on my AmEx and they said no
right yeah she wasn't 18. yeah they
looked at the actual date they were like
no no yeah that makes sense
um what about business credit because
I'm like uh right now I have a few llc's
and
um my friend just connected me with a
accountant to try to kind of turn one of
my LLCs into an S corp
um when it comes to business credit
business credit is one of those things
that a lot of people don't talk about
right and it's very important and it's a
it's something you can leverage
extremely uh high if you know what
you're doing yeah right so let's say you
have a 720 credit score I got a 720
quieter score
um I get my tax ID right I go on the IRS
website I get a tax ID I create my LLC
right separate entity for myself I go
open up a bank account uh you know
whatever it is Radio Investments right
right boom all right that's separate
from me now I go to Chase Inc I go to
MasterCard I go to American Express who
at American Express right and now I
apply
with my new uh entity for a business
credit card right yeah so they'll do a
soft inquiry on my personal right
because you're behind the loc yeah as
long as I have a 725 score and they'll
prove me right but it will never show on
my personal credit
so now it doesn't affect my debt to
income ratio so now on this side I might
have a couple hundred thousand dollars
in credit credit cards yeah but it
doesn't show here right so it keeps it
separate from my personal name but now
by me doing this with some credit cards
I could take the money cash it out
and invest in real estate or a new
business by leveraging my credit wow so
if you have a 720 personal credit score
at least yeah yeah you got to have that
you you start at LLC you start at S Corp
you'll be able to get qualified for
credit cards through your business that
don't necessarily touch your personal
credit yep it's always separate even
cars you you could buy cars under your
business name
right and like that's the another thing
as a write-off like there are certain
types of cars that you can like if it's
a certain weight of a car I think if
it's like I forget what the what the
weight is well pretty much any car you
know like like all you know even our
cars are expensive cars like we have it
under the LC and we write them all off
because technically we drive around and
so how do you do that property give me
that give me that game man because
that's something that like I was talking
to uh because like last year did I
[ __ ] wrote a fat check to the IRS and
this was I didn't have an accountant I
wasn't really like
this year I'm gonna have an account and
like I said where I'm trying to move so
many stuff that's happening in my
personal accounts over to my business
accounts and the lady I'm talking to is
like yo if you have if it looks like
you're gonna have to like write a 60 or
70 000 check this year like you could
just go buy a car with that instead of
giving it to the IRS so let's say for
example right I have
I go out there and I buy a Bentley right
I'm paying two thousand dollars a month
it's not my personal name right I can't
write that off right it's in your
personal name you can't write down right
now let's see a same scenario but I put
it under the business right so now let's
say I'm paying two thousand dollars a
month uh you know 24 000 a year right
give or take I'm a realtor when I go
show properties to people
I drive my belly so now my insurance my
payment my uh whatever I spend on gas is
all right off all of it well it's all a
write-off so think about it this way
right uh is a percentage because I heard
I heard like certain cards you only
write off a percentage right but uh but
you could all but can't you write off
the depreciation all up front yeah you
could do there's a whole bunch of things
once it's in your business name right
that you could do but Sim very simple
right
a hundred thousand I mean a hundred
thousand dollars a year right I gotta
pay let's say thirty thousand dollars
back to the to the IRS taxes right in
taxes right thirty thousand dollars
I have a Bentley that I use for my
business right I paid twenty four
thousand dollars so a year let's say I
could write off twenty dollar twenty
thousand is a write-off so I'm driving
20 out of the 24. yeah so I'm driving my
dream car
right and now I'm saving money on my
taxes because instead of paying 30 you
got to pay 10. yep
and this is my as long as it's under my
company see to me this is the [ __ ] that
people like these people these are like
the life hacks yeah where it's like like
you said like like uh that's that's
that's what I'm trying to figure out man
like I feel like the last few years I
made so much money I made the most money
I've ever made in my life and I'm like
trying to kind of figure out like the
rich guy [ __ ]
the tax game all that [ __ ] man there's
so many loopholes there's so many things
that like you have to because the more
you make the more they want and then
because you'd rather drive your dream
car than right give that money to Uncle
Sam yeah because [ __ ] them yeah you know
like you're throwing money away it makes
no sense right and then eventually the
worst part is as you get older then you
got to do estate planning because when
you die even though you pay taxes on the
money that you already made while you
are alive you got to pay your your
family has they're gonna have to pay
taxes on your money yeah yeah it could
be a crazy sum depending on the state is
that a national thing or does it depend
on the state is different right yeah
it's more the conservative states are
like a little more chill on this state
tax [ __ ] right but you but you know it
was like who was it uh
this guy didn't think he was gonna die
right I wish nobody fought um Tony
Soprano right from uh James got James
James yeah he did he did a plan
um he kind of died unexpectedly yeah he
died unexpectedly and he did a plan for
that and
his wealth uh I was reading that the
family lost a lot of it because it
wasn't planned because he went to taxes
yeah
by the way kind of a jersey Legend I'm
not sure if he's from Jersey but Tony
Soprano was from Jersey bro that's like
one of the best TV shows ever of all
time all the time of all time